i was on bill maher's show on friday
night and it was a lot of fun
it was uh before shabbat so i was able
to actually do the panel
uh the the other person on the panel was
malcolm nance who you may have seen on
msnbc
uh he's the guy who's constantly
claiming that donald trump was a
vladimir putin stooge he's made some
pretty extraordinary claims to that
effect without the supporting evidence
to
back it and a bunch of topics were
discussed among them authoritarianism
and critical race
theory and in case you missed it i
thought i'd play a little bit
for it of it for you today so
we sort of started by discussing what
authoritarianism looks like
and nance and mar were making the case
that authoritarianism is really just
centralized government control well
first of all i mean quick point
when it comes to centralized government
control it seems that
one party is much more interested in
actual centralized government control
than the other party
that is number number one number two
when it comes to soft authoritarian
control like the stuff that you worry
about on a daily basis the stuff that
affects your life
that is coming from a wide variety of
institutions that have decided to mirror
the priorities of your political
opponents
and shut you down this is the point that
i made with bill and uh
and with malcolm on friday night on
hbo's real time
the question is is not whether
authoritarianism exists on all sides i
think there are plenty of authoritarians
on all sides the question is where does
the institutional power lie
and if the answer is that donald trump
tweeting and being a jerk is the essence
of authoritarianism
as opposed to say joe biden the
president of the united states saying
this week
that he doesn't care whether it's
constitutional for the cdc to extend the
eviction moratorium he's going to do it
anyway
i mean that that seems better okay the
this
point is one that the left the obsession
with trump
for the left is really a bit of
projection
because donald trump tweeted a lot of
bad stuff
and he acted in in bizarre and in i
would say
authoritarian ways like his manner
bordered on that
did any of that end up making it into
actual policy
the answer is pretty much no and so they
focused in on january 6th right i've
been saying for a long time january 6th
is the peg that democrats are going to
count on
when it comes to 2022 i don't think it's
going to pay off for them
and this is sort of a point that i made
on mars show
so malcolm nance tried to suggest that
40 000 people invaded the capital
on january 6th that is just flatly
untrue it is flatly untrue and it's
important that it's untrue here's the
point that i made on on mars show
40 000 people did not assault the
capital okay that's just factually
inaccurate
there were maybe a thousand people that
is not making light of the evil of those
people who all will end up rotting in
prison as they should
how many people came to that rally were
all of those people assaulting the
capital is that
all marched on the capital and then the
leading they all marched
yeah it isn't no yes no it is inaccurate
malcolm
x ben well yes you're not mentioning
them now can we have a terrible habit of
conflating people
who do actual violent activity with a
broader rubric
of everyone for example voted for trump
which was 75 million people
and that really is ugly okay not only is
it ugly it is authoritarian and intent
because the goal is if you can castigate
everybody on the other side of the aisle
as a criminal then you can treat them as
criminals
and and malcolm unfortunately has a
rather significant habit of doing that
and suggesting that everybody who is on
the trumpy side of the aisle anybody who
votes republican anybody
who has pulled the lever for trump that
all of those people
are implicitly involved or at least
winking at january 6th and thus must be
treated
as outside the overton window and
basically can do whatever you want
to them okay i pointed out as well
that the institutional power is coming
from the democrats at this point
and the the it's hilarious to watch
people continue on the left to just
shout about trump democrats are in
charge of every major institution in the
country including
all all of the branches of elected
government at this point
right now the house the senate and the
presidency of the united states are all
controlled by the democratic party
it is the democratic party large scale
across the united states currently
engaged
in mass mandates vaccine mandates and
lockdowns so
for all the talk about tucker carlson
who again you mentioned is not a
governmental figure or donald trump
who's not been in office since january
last i checked
it seems that the great threat that
people are experiencing right now is
from the soft institutions
right the institutions the facebooks and
the twitters and the corporate world
right all those institutions on a soft
level and on a governmental level
the people who are actually experiencing
control top down from the government
the people at the top of the government
right now are democrats okay and uh and
malcolm nance then tried to blame trump
for that which was kind of
hilarious again the trump of it like at
a certain point guys you're gonna have
to recognize that
what you're calling for your agenda is a
big
government top-down campaign for
censorship
and control it doesn't matter whether
you're talking about covet lockdowns or
whether we're talking about
revising the standards for the fcc so
you can ban fox news
there's only one side of the aisle
that's really attempting to quash the
other side of the aisle
okay then we got to the issue of
critical race theory
and uh and this i will say was just
straight amusing
so i talked about what critical race
theory actually constitutes and uh
i will say that it is amazing to see how
critical race theory defenders
literally refuse to defend the
principles of critical race theory on
their own terms
they just play this ridiculous
trying to nail jello to the wall game so
bill
asked me to define critical race theory
i defined it nance agreed with the
definition of critical race theory and
then proceeded
to elide the entire definition it was
really an impressive show
critical race theory essentially argues
that racism is baked into all the
systems of american society
and that any sort of neutral system is
in fact a
guise for racial power if we agree that
history should be taught
why are you defending critical race
theory which is not history did i not
just say a moment ago that i think that
term has been hijacked and that's not
okay so let's say critical race
i'm going to go back and repeat that i
didn't say that okay you
are literally defending critical race
theory by redefining it as just teaching
history which is a cheap semantic trick
and you know it is this what you do on
your show cause it sucks
ice you know nothing
[Applause]
malcolm i appreciate that but i will i
will i will comfort myself
by sleeping on my bed made of money okay
um by the way my bed isn't actually made
of money it's a helix fleet mattress and
it is just glorious let me just tell you
i could sleep on a bed made of money i
just feel like it would be really really
uncomfortable like money is not all that
comfortable
and shockingly not worth all that much
as joe biden continues to inflate the
currency
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that
make it happen gang